[Music]
[Music]
Luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and we're going to
Alaska yeah
now you guys may not know this but I was
born and raised alaskan most of my
family still live there so every once in
a while we like to go up and visit
family and do some fishing and camping
and just let the boys kind of experience
my childhood memories a little bit we
are going to have a ball I'm going to be
there for two weeks but first we've got
to fly on a plane for nine hours to get
from here in Virginia all the way to
Anchorage Alaska it's going to be a long
day
[Music]
big fish large buddy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we made it guys we're here in Alaska and
it's only 4:00 a.m. Virginia time we
finally made it after being on a plane
for nine hours and change we landed in
Anchorage a little before midnight last
night and got to see a little bit of the
Sun disappear right as we were landing
but we've got a full day today we've got
to go and pick up with some gear from
the fishing store get ready say hi to
some family and then we're gonna head up
to a cabin up near Talkeetna and do some
fishing but first we need to get some
feed Tommy what do you say we go get
some food yeah all right let's do it
so we're gonna get a bunch of bagels and
waffles and pancakes and some reindeer
sausage bagels so this is gonna be good
[Music]
all right Tommy hungry I hope you're
hungry but is a lot of food oh we got
all right buddy look at that
tell me what's that over there you see
that polar bears a lot bigger than your
head see El Kheir caddis fours when he
goes number ones
yeah
yeah they are the big old propeller on
this
or headed up to Talkeetna near the
castle in the river to stand our
family's cabin and without hopefully
catch some silver salmon tonight and be
having fresh grilled salmon but the
person starts by a plan B just to pay
sniffing
[Applause]
[Music]
Rotech food reindeer bagel dog baby
that reindeer used to laugh and qualify
fabien Tommy I love you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys like these bozos yeah that's
growing up bad and look at the loft
yeah pretty nice huh as it is are
beavers see this is a beaver hides
there's the bear claws you like that
yeah there yo there's some whale baleen
and some ducks that we shot in Arkansas
trout from the Katmai River yeah I
carved that when I was in high school I
don't know whose deer that is being
Uncle Jim's
[Music]
hey I can't believe we're in Alaska fish
it to is it it great all the river looks
a little high but not bad at all all
right we don't want any beer here
[Music]
Tommy are you cold the door a guy I
could be fixed up he picks up mommy I'm
sorry you're not feeling a little bud
okay we'll go get you dry
[Music]
long nosed sucker closest thing to a
carp we get in Alaska anywhere you find
salmon and even a few places you don't
you generally find these and you got a
mouth on the bottom of their chin great
at detecting salmon eggs and eating they
love to eat salmon eggs so if you're
fishing for salmon with salmon eggs
they'll often catch these good-sized
little fish though it's about a normal
size full-grown one they get a little
bigger than this but not too often but a
great fish back well I've been fishing
here for about two hours and so far I
haven't seen any salmon I haven't seen
anything run or jumper not really any
bites I could say that's a salmon I've
gotten a lot of little nibbles which
probably Dolly Varden or white fish or
bourbon or grayling good who knows it's
been a little bit of a slow year from
what I hear and I'm also a little bit
late that's the real nail biter is this
is the third week of August and normally
the first week of August is the sweet
time that you want to be here so
hopefully I haven't missed the salmon
run but mornings are often best and it's
evening it's slowly getting dark so
maybe tomorrow morning I'll have a
little bit better luck we'll see what
happens
that my friends is a silver salmon oh my
goodness I think the school just came
well I gotta get another rig out there
the schools in thick I was just in the
middle of telling you guys how slow it
was and WHAM the by alarm goes off and I
catch this pretty little silver salmon
get the hook out throw my rig back out
there and before I've even done another
fish no I'm just getting another bite
this is how it is you know it's
absolutely nothing going on then a
school of them comes in and it's red hot
with salmon it's all about timing it
doesn't matter how good of a fisherman
you are if you're not in the right spot
at the right time you're not gonna catch
anything and frankly when you're in the
right spot at the right time it's hard
to miss it's really hard to screw it up
well I've been in Alaska for 24 hours
now and I already have four salmon
fillets so things are off to a good
start this is gonna be it's gonna be a
good trip ran out of daylight but I'm
gonna try to get some sleep get up early
and see if we can't catch some more
tomorrow morning will taught me filling
the river he got himself pretty wet so I
got to dry his socks out before tomorrow
so not quite sure this microwave doesn't
have a sock setting so I'm gonna give it
a minute or two see if that helps all
right it's a beautiful morning it's a
little before 7:00 a.m. and I'm gonna go
see if we can't get some more salmon oh
I'm really I'm gonna have to sleep
sometime during this trip but it's not
gonna be today
you can catch them in the middle of the
day but man right around sunrise
is the best fortunately sunrise in the
summertime in Alaska is very early so
yeah this a beautiful spot but this is
bear country in the middle of salmon
season so I'm a packin my heat got a can
of bear mace the Alaskan state bird the
mosquito suckers are huge up here what a
great way to spend the morning I just
had a ball cash in this sucker all right
let's get cooking I have hunted and
gathered my love Nathan those are salmon
yeah we're gonna eat it for lunch okay
we'll put some sprinkles on
and frosting okay we'll get the frosting
on there too
[Music]
there you go fresh Alaska silver salmon
I caught a few minutes ago hmm
that's really good
it spawns oh it's delicious mmm
gonna trade this is salmon see here see
we go dip it in the sauce
hey I like that mmm
what did it taste what do you think good
do you want some more
[Music]
all right lunch is served so we've got
with some barbecued corn fresh salmon
kale salad rosemary a loaf of bread like
there's like rosemary and olive oil
blueberries
let's do this now that right there is an
Alaskan lunch look at that fresh salmon
some blueberries this is how you go to
Alaska right here this is what fish is
all about guys let's go on four wheelers
[Music]
[Music]
well my naughty husband I love you still
[Music]
yeah funny did you like the
four-wheelers did you have fun you want
the cheese go for it oh yeah thanks for
watching and don't forget to check out
part 2 of our Alaskan adventure where me
and my brother go hunting for ptarmigan
and caribou and fly fishing for grayling
on the Denali Highway and if you liked
this video don't forget to click
subscribe to the outdoor boys YouTube
channel we put out new videos every week
thanks for watching